and I think that you're really talking
about kind of the the collision of a
couple of trends here so recently I saw
on Twitter that you were talking about
this idea that like science is not
consensus driven right that's how the
whole point of science but then how do
you balance that in your mind with
things like content moderation and
censorship where there are accepted
norms there's accepted pieces of
information and sometimes actually the
people who end up having the
breakthrough or coming from a place that
was previously thought to be taboo or
false even and like how do you sift
through that as you're taking all this
input of information and trying to
really kind of come up with a maybe not
a conclusion but actually I got thesis
as to how you think the world will move
in the future so a few different things
so on the sort of institution of science
itself where there's actually a lot of
negative things about the
institutionalization but science is a
process does not depend on a consensus
it just depends on a conjecture there's
evidence you know based on observations
from a hypothesis conjecture and then
you can make a reasonable conclusion
basically tentatively held nobody ever
says with certitude this is what is and
often times old ideas get replaced by
better explanations or bad explanations
get replaced by good explanations and
that's how science progresses you know I
think it was Linus Pauling I may be
messing up the attribution who said that
science proceeds one funeral at a time
and so a lot of the old guard who gets
famous and you know gets a chaired
department and has all the postdocs that
want to work for them and gets the fame
and gets the appointments and gets the
Board of Directors at engineering
companies got famous in many cases for
you know flawed or bad explanations that
were widely accepted until some young
hotshot you know full of piss and
vinegar this is like no I don't think
that's the way it works and then you
know they upturn it and this process for
peace so there's a predictability to the
unpredictability of how science itself
advances when attempt when it comes to
you know policy whether it's you know
for a city or for a company or for how
somebody runs their family or the
choices that you make of what you put in
your body you know that that is less
about science itself as a process and
more about prescriptions and advice and
risk management when it comes to you
know sorting through everything that you
might read online
and you know recommendations and you
know criticisms you know that that's
just all sort of analysis based on you
know what everybody's putting out there
but but science itself I feel you know
just sort of absolutist about it is is a
process that is just constantly trying
to come up with better and better
questions and better and better
explanations but it's an endless process
because whatever we hold to be
tentatively true today is very likely to
be overturned in you know some point in
the future by somebody that's just come
up with a better explanation